Star wars, it's a war movie right Star Wars
But the thing is even the edgiest Star Wars movie is only rated pg-13 and you know
I'm wondering what would it look like to actually make Star Wars rated R to make it authentic
To the battle experience and what the heck happens gonna get shot with a laser gun right now
It's just like a little puff like you're in power rangers
But you're those things need blasting like a hole for your body Star Wars definitely have a charm as its innocent hero adventure film
But for this one video we're gonna do something special
We're gonna give you a taste what Star Wars would be like to visit rated R
We have the power to do what if here what would it look like if it was made for adults what if we replace the
lightsabers with like katanas earth wars man just
like Darth Vader choke - dude
You could actually make it look painful now veins started bulge and like their eyes start to like mousse, you know, yep
Oh man. So this this is the darkest moment in the entire prequel trilogy or
He's still sad. Akira style just like yeah, everything ladies like dumb. Jedi
Nothing better than me here. Oh my goodness. What is this? Wait clay, you don't know about this scene No
He falls through a trapdoor in the floor and use your
And then in this shots, yeah wasn't cut too after this
We're 66 feels pretty appropriate
I think so like it has it has a lot of hits we can all come together and take a moment from that that's gonna
Do I'll be one hitting the rocks. I'll do tall head getting shot up
So we all pick him over from the kid shot. All right, guys, we got work cut out for us
Jump to Lightspeed. Hope we don't have a burnout
Attractive footage that's easy extend the shot a little bit more to make it longer. That's easy clean plate the water out
That's easy first challenge comes with replacing the water with rocks, but honestly, that's pretty easy to check us out
Cinema 4d plus octane in a sweet rock asset well placed in well-lit Bowen
It's in but you say hey, what's that stuff bouncing around the rocks?
Well, those are limbs that I made and sent him up 4d. I couldn't find Obi Wan's lizard Steve beast
so what I did was just got some dinosaur from turbosquid and chopped that up through some dynamics on its limbs and
Gave it some initial force
Down to the ground most of the dinosaur hasn't disappeared
But I'm filling that in with blood and smoke and mirrors and crap you guys. I got the wait to see that
Stay tuned. Don't touch that dial. Don't pull that crank. Don't yank that chain don't flush the toilet because we'll be back. I
Sense a disturbance in what Rick in?
of course now in the internet
There's a dark side to the internet and a light side the only way to pre balance
mister today's sponsor expressvpn
You see without a VPN you could fall prey to the dark side because hackers
Internet providers and cell phone providers can just take your information and do whatever they want with it
Using a VPN like expressvpn
Encrypts that information and makes sure is protected and safe. They've gotten best-in-class encryption
They have 24/7 customer support. They have server locations in over 94 countries and apps for every device
There is hope just go to expressvpn comm Goro crew. You can get expressvpn for just $7 a month
Also, if you sign up for a one-year you get three months free. That's e x PR
ESS VPN comm such cool real crew. You can get expressed VPN and never fall prey to the dark side
Here is the original shot
So Jedi can't handle it early to stormtrooper shooting at him. I
Want to make this way more violent if you seen Akira, there's a one guy who's stealing the kid at the beginning
He gets all shot up with a riot police. I wanted to take that as my inspiration
First off not nearly enough later start being fired
So I went and I cranked up the lasers and I perfectly matched my lasers the lasers from a movie and the reason they look
Really good is because I'm using andrew kramer's saber plugin
Andrew, basically went and made the best laser slash lightsaber plugin for After Effects for free Sun Video Copilot net
So if you needed you lasers or light sabers or whatever go check it out. It has a lot of really cool features
So use that to duplicate these lasers and make my own. Oh
My gosh a lot
I also use the liquify tool to like have parts his head bursts as well as like clothing
This gives you motivation for all my blood spurts. I used action VFX as blood hits pack
I just have a lot of blur going on the initial frames and things I'm bright and hazy and then it kind of sharpens ups
The shot goes on the one more thing. I did. I did some bullet hits
We have a bullet hit on his eye here
for example
I hit shot in the side of the head and the way I did that so I combined the flesh wound development from action essentials
With a blood splatter and those two on top of him give it a pretty convincing
Blood splat phone as a final like little touch. I put some blood splatters in the ground
I hope you enjoy a more accurate representation of what stormtrooper lasers would do to you clone trooper lasers. Sorry difference
So I finished my shot
but I was feeling kind of hollow and
Incomplete and I couldn't figure out why until I realize is because I have this opportunity
To do something that I'm sure everyone has always wanted to do and that's to mutilate Jar Jar Binks
So I thought what if instead of his tongue going numb his whole head explodes so looking at the truck from the outside
There's a few things that he got to do first. She got to track the shot
He got to create a clean plate that goes where he is. I added him back in with some like find edges effects and some
Turbulent displace on top of that to kind of get that electrical sort of look on top of all of him Jar Jar
Jar Jar Binks
With something like this more is better having a lot of different elements
You got the lightning. Then you have the sparks. You have the tared skin of a cloth simulation. You have the actual blood burst
Yes, smoke bursts. It kind of just gives that misty look so you actually have like some vaporized
And then to top it off you have a
Severed head beautiful how many elements is enough elements? The answer is never
no, that's not you can never have enough elements always put in more because chances are it'll look better when you have more contrast and
variety
Individuals going into something thing you want to be careful about is hitting that point of just visual noise where there's so much stuff happening
So dense, every single image has so many things going on
You want to make sure each thing that you add is distinct now
this is an example of using just nothing but
Existing video files that I already had that I can just throw in there à la carte
But Sam over there is actually working on a custom blood simulation for his shot
And that'll be one of a kind. I want to see that
what makes these little
Experiments so great
Is it opens up these opportunities for us to explore and learn and try out some new techniques?
We've been wanting to do for my shot
I got just that I've been experimenting with this new plugin called X particles which allows us to simulate fire smoke
liquids soft bodies rigid bodies young Jedi bodies
These bodies are plumb full of milk. Laureen's I got to put that to work today
So he's falling so fast that his body
combusts into a million little pieces if you actually watched the scene where he threatens the babies with the lifesaver it
Immediately cuts to Padme his apartment. So we took that q this is probably where he's gonna land
Basically, I'm gonna have the young wing hit the glass of Padme apartment. So this is very strong glass
I'm not gonna have the glass like shatter into pieces, but I'm going to have the young wing explode into pieces
So the way I want to do that is using a fluid simulation
So in order to make a fluid simulation, I need to model the environment, roughly. This is my little environment here
So we have a floor area here. Here's our glass
so rather than actually
simulate something falling down and
exploding that I basically just have the body at the glass and I'm using this really rough model of like arms and legs as
The source in which the liquid is going to emit from? I've got all this fluid here
I'm basically just saying just don't just go from this moment because it honestly something's falling from that high velocity
It's gonna go all over the place. Basically then I'm just telling the fluid. Hey fluid
I want you to have a lot of friction, you know, I want it to stick and slide a little bit though
Now that I have my particles simulated here. It's actually take a a measure
It basically looks at these particles and builds a mesh around them turns these particles into something renderable and physical
hitting the glass
Exploding all over the place. It's very messy. Now the second half the blood is one of those cool advanced techniques
I've never messed with before it's called making a wet and mat
this is really good for
splatters and stains the trail of the fluid that
Follows something like this if I had a sponge and I just wiped it on the wall
It would leave a wet trail behind
So hence the name wet map these particles now are painting residuals smearing of like some goop running down the glass
Boom man, you see how that stuff is exploding. Holy Frick
Today we're watching all of our hard work together
We got each worked on a shot and now it's time to watch them all together with glorious sound design
I know cliff did some Bo whether that's gonna be good. Hey, we decided to make Star Wars naughty because we're all big boys
The fleet just moved out to fight speed and we're preparing to
Order 60
Oh
There are too many of them, what are we going to do
I'm sure you're alright
Oh
Voiceover. Oh no, I'm bringing our daughter into the tower
The perverted yoga thing really Wow, I was not expecting that whereas all the effects we added like NYX NYX on a good
Saying yeah, I cut it out above his bottom jaw, so it's just the top part of his job tongue wiggling out. Oh
Yeah, so do you guys think terms of who's gonna see this and like squeeze it into his special special edition?
This is how it was meant to be. How about really meant to be did you hear that?
He had an extra like special
Edition that he's been sitting on for years for the newest release of a new hope when it came out with Disney
Plus there's actually a new edit around when Han shoots Guido Guido?